Samsung has just decided to take on
Apple in a category that nobody else
wanted to touch now for a long time
Apple has made premium displays that so
many Mac users and even some windows
users have loved because of not only the
design but the build quality and the
looks along with the specs we waited for
an affordable monitor from Apple for
many years especially after Apple
discontinued their super popular
Thunderbolt display but then when one
came out it cost five thousand dollars
and had a one thousand dollar stand
which was a really nice display but a
six grand almost nobody can afford it
and then a few years later after many
rumors of having a nice mini LED 27 inch
display Apple released the studio
display which was still expensive at
sixteen hundred dollars but it did not
have mini LED it was a regular 5K LCD
display which was still nice and it was
an upgrade from the LG 5K but the
quality was very similar the main
difference was the design the fact that
it is made by Apple made out of aluminum
it has a great stand doesn't wobble like
crazy like the LG 5K and it had a better
webcam supposedly now we actually really
like that display our main editor
Angelica uses it paired to the Mac
Studio and those things came out at the
same time and we use it just because it
is nice and it ties in well with the
ecosystem and mainly because it is a 5K
display where most of the competition
still makes 4K displays and for video
editing that 5K is really nice now it
does have that e13 built into it but
unfortunately Apple really didn't take
advantage of it and you have other
competitors now that are starting to
make unique displays for example Samsung
once again we made a video on the M8
that was about half the price of the
studio display but had so many more
features and I absolutely loved it I
gave it a great review but it was still
4K but now Samsung has just announced
this competitor that literally looks
like a knockoff of the display and it is
a 27 inch 5K disc blade that has some
really great features that might be a
studio display killer and I'll explain
exactly why this thing is called the
viewfinity S9 if you take a look you
might even get confused for the studio
display because they look so similar now
the bezels here they are actually
Slimmer than the studio display and
you'll notice a webcam right at the top
which I I think is going to be killer
but first one thing that really stands
out other than the resolution is the
fact that it is 99 DCI P3 the same exact
color accuracy as the studio display now
not only that it has built-in color
calibration which is excellent for
people doing photo editing video editing
has a low Delta e and it has USB and
Thunderbolts 4. now one of the issues
that the studio display has is the fact
that it only has Thunderbolt And there's
not even a power button it turns on when
it connects and it's mostly using
software now this thing has a display
port and an HDMI built in as well so
with the studio space you're spending
1600 bucks but you are limited because
you can't use that with everything so
Samsung's viewfinity S9 as they are
calling it is a lot more flexible now
along with that not only does it have
this kind of similar design but it is
also built out of aluminum including the
stand that is where morphs companies
don't want to go costs a lot more money
takes more time to do that so everybody
uses plastic and people love Apple's
displays because the build quality is
great the stand is great doesn't wobble
around well now we have another kind of
luxury display option that is made out
of aluminum now the studio display has a
good webcam like they showed off on
stage but when people actually got and
started using it it looked pretty
terrible so much so that apple had to
address it saying that there are softer
issues for that 1080p webcam and put out
an update now we actually tested out the
update we got the beta software and it
did make it a little bit better but it
was still pretty bad and we showed off a
third-party piece of software that
allowed you to use your iPhone phone in
order to use that instead of the webcam
get much better quality the difference
was massive and apple actually went
ahead and copied that app and they built
that right into Mac OS so you don't have
to use their 1080p webcam well this
Samsung actually includes a 4K webcam
instead of 1080P and it also can crop in
and track you just like Apple software
so that is a copy now there's no images
from that 4K but I assume it's going to
look quite a bit better and it is also
going to be detachable just like on the
Samsung M8 so you can pop it off if you
want for privacy if you don't want
anybody to turn that on remotely if you
care a lot about that now another issue
with most monitors on the market is that
they are advertised as having HDR but a
lot of them only hit 350 nits 400 nits
whereas a studio display went from 500
up to 600 so that was an improvement and
the HR looked pretty good for an LCD
display now this Samsung also hits 600
nits for HDR so it's another copy and I
wonder if there's a chance that the
actual LCD panel that is in that Samsung
could be the same exact panel in the
studio display that is definitely a
possibility now with the studio display
one thing a lot of people complained
about is that the stand that it comes
with it is not really adjustable the
1600 model only has tilt and that is it
now if you want to have height
adjustment you have to spend two
thousand dollars to upgrade that in
order to have a stand that is similar to
the 6K xdr display and to be able to
raise it higher because from the factory
it is somewhat low for most people well
this Samsung display actually has that
built in and you you can also rotate the
display and they have an image of that
now the one thing that I am concerned
about is that the Samsung is a matte
display now their images make it look
glossy so I don't know what exactly
they're doing but on the studio display
you actually have to pay extra another
300 to get Apple's Nano texture which is
a little bit matte but not as bad as
most displays to reduce reflectivity but
the Samsung is already mad so we're
going to check it out and we will do a
comparison to see how well that display
does and if the matte makes the detail
go down a lot like it does on most
displays now what we do not know is the
price tag it's going to come early this
year but we have no pricing so we don't
know what it's going to be at now I know
it's not going to be cheap but I highly
doubt it's going to be sixteen hundred
dollars either so my guess is is it will
be cheaper and with more features built
in and along with all of these things
it's also going to run their tizen OS so
just like the M8 you're going to be able
to use a bunch of different smart apps
streaming services without even having
any computer or anything connected to it
which I think is a killer feature and
all displays should have that if they
have a good processor which this one
will have one that's good enough and
unfortunately the studio display even
though it has an a13 built in with 64
gigabytes of storage built in well
Apple's not allowing you to use anything
like that it doesn't have Apple TV built
in or anything else so they are limiting
it compared to this Samsung so it's
going to be interesting to see what this
comes out price wise I think it's going
to be a great display you guys let me
know your thoughts are you okay with
them pretty much copying it but making
it better with having more inputs having
a better webcam more features out of the
box like with the stand is this
something you'd want to buy AI instead
of the studio display if you own a Mac
and you typically Buy Apple products I
think for a lot of you guys
um this might make a whole ton of sense
especially if it has the same display
now if you're gonna buy a 5k Studio
display from Apple check out the YouTube
shopping feature where you can go ahead
and check that out and pick one of those
up and click above to subscribe if you
guys want to see our comparison with the
Samsung as soon as it comes out against
the Apple Studio display check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been Max and I'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
foreign